[Musique]
jean marc sylvestre bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin de bonne heure sur rt
france alors l'année 2020 s'est terminée
sans trop de dégâts dans les entreprises
mais beaucoup d'experts experts
craignent le pire pour 2021
beaucoup de faillites et de chômage vous
faites partie des économistes qui ont
fait des diagnostics très prudent alors
où est ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui
jean-marc elle ajouté c'est vrai que
j'ai jamais cru à l'effondrement total
de l'économie ou à la ruine du système
dont je suis très prudent à l'égard des
prévisions qui sont faites pour pour
2021 2020 s'est terminé avec un bilan
finalement meilleur que ce que l'on
craignait un encours de crise donc ça va
donner un tout petit peu raison
d'ailleurs la bourse n'a pas bougé elle
a même terminé les marchés financiers
ont terminé à un niveau supérieur à
celui où il était au début de l'année
or les négocier anticipe beaucoup les
beaucoup des choses ça s'est mieux passé
pourquoi ça s'est mieux passé d'abord
parce que la crise n'a pas détruit des
actifs de production sap a été une
guerre avec des bombardements
ni un tremblement de terre les immeubles
les usines les bureaux sont restés
debout
les camions les avions sont restés en
bon état ils sont arrêtés sur les
parkings bien sûr mais mais mais on est
à tout peut repartir tout peut repartir
d'autant et c'est la deuxième raison
c'est que les aides de l'état ont été
massives en 2020 l'état à compenser les
pertes de chiffres d'affaires l'état a
suspendu le paiement des charges les
moratoires sur sur les impôts et l'état
par le chômage notamment le chômage
partiel à protéger les contrats de
travail donc
j'ajoute j'ajoute une troisième raison
si vous voulez c'est que beaucoup
d'entreprises ont commencé à s'adapter
par la digitalisation n'en parle pas
beaucoup mais vous savez il ya ça
tombait ils ont fait preuve d'une énorme
résilience à ce problème notamment
pendant le premier confinement les
françaises sont mis au travail au
télétravail
ils ont modifié leurs habitudes ils ont
découvert une très grande capacité
d'adaptation donc le système a
d'ailleurs fonctionné très fort après le
1er avr est le premier de confinement là
à partir de mai juin juillet août
septembre
ça a été quand même un peu d'artifices
en a fait des taux de progression
été capables de compenser un peu la
perte donc les lords et confinement
partielle des couvre-feux y avait une
pédagogie qui s'est installé le système
je le répète n'a pas été ruinée alors il
ya des secteurs qui ont été très très
abîmée à voulez-vous vous les connaissez
on vient d'en parler l'hôtellerie toutes
ces activités qui draine le public ont
été littéralement écrasé les cafés
restaurants les théâtres les cinémas les
bayat
c'est ça cette épouvantable pas un euro
de chiffre d'affaires de plus mais
l'état a continué d aider et mais c'est
évidemment pas la solution pour l'année
prochaine alors pourquoi attendre
l'année qui vient précisément jean
maxime s en vont la crains parce que en
2021 la situation va être quand même
très compliqué parce qu'on va suspendre
on va commencer à suspendre toutes les
aides
il va falloir que les entreprises qui
ont fait des dettes commence à réfléchir
comment on va les payer ça ça va pas
être cinq
et là il va y avoir des faillites il va
y avoir des plans sociaux mais je crois
que les difficultés vont surtout surgir
dans les entreprises qui était malade
avant la crise et qui vont être encore
plus malade
après vous savez il ya pas mal
d'entreprises qu'on appelle des
entreprises zombies
pas très joli comme terme les
entreprises qui sont très perfusé par
l'état très soutenu très aidé parce
qu'elles ne sont pas adaptés parce
qu'elles sont pas modernisé parce
qu'elles vivent sur un petit territoire
et elle elle courra l'asphyxient alors
vous avez beaucoup de petits cafés
restaurants par exemple qui vivait pas
très bien avant tre 20 soit même d'un
villes qui sont très utiles pour créer
du lien social dans certains quartiers
mais qui auront du mal à repartir les
difficultés vont surgir aussi dans les
entreprises qui n'ont pas su ou qui
n'ont pas pu s'adapter aux changements
le e-commerce les livraisons à domicile
le click and collect le télétravail ch
tout ça c'est pas évident ça s'est
installé durablement notamment dans des
catégories qu'il en avait pas l'habitude
ou qui n'étaient pas familiarisé tout ça
les seniors par exemple de plus de 60
ans si on me alors tout ça va
s'installer définitivement et vous avez
des activités pour lesquelles ça va
quand même être très difficile le
propriétaire d'un cinéma par exemple va
pouvoir se demander si ces clients qui
ont pris un abonnement à netflix
reviendront dans la
lorsque la salle sera ouvert et ils ont
raison on se le demande et parce qu'il
va y avoir là un vrai problème tous ses
voyages au bout du monde était organisée
par les entreprises ces séminaires
d'entreprises
tout ça va se raréfier beaucoup d'hôtels
vivaient du tourisme d'affaires or le
tourisme d'affaires va être
progressivement remplacés il l'est déjà
par des relations skype ou des relations
zoom on s'aperçoit que c'est pratique on
s'aperçoit que c'est moins cher donc il
va y avoir des plans sociaux c'est vrai
il va y avoir des faillites c'est vrai
et le gros problème pour l'état va être
de décider de quelle entreprise on va
aider quelle entreprise on va on va
accompagner dans l'adaptation et celles
pour lesquelles on ne pourra pas faire
grand chose
il va falloir faire des arbitrages très
compliqué très difficile
ils vont être d'autant plus difficile
que la capacité d'endettement de l'état
n'est pas sans limite donc la capacité
d'aider les entreprises va diminuer et
jean marc lanne et 2021 elle va dépendre
de quoi on l'a écouté on le sait tous où
elle va dépendre de virus elle va
dépendre de ces variants elle va
dépendre surtout de la vaccination
ça va dépendre aussi de la solidarité
européenne parce que c'est l'union
européenne qui nous permettent
d'emprunter de l'argent à bas prix comme
c'est le cas actuellement
mais tout ça est quand même très très
important parce que on ne peut revenir à
la normale à la vie normale que si la
confiance revient
on pourra remettre la clé dans le camion
la clé dans l'avion pour tous pour des
marques à kuan local pour les confiance
dans notre voisin dans notre partenaire
dans les gens avec qui on en vit
actuellement l'état de l'opinion est
assez démoralisé sais pas merci beaucoup
jean marc sylvestre pour toutes ces
précisions
c'était à l'édito économique comme tous
les mercredis merci à la semaine
prochaine